[Music]
to ask you have you talked to or heard
from crystals at all since his accident
I have it no no comment on that one
now Dancing with the Stars you sadly
were gone so soon
did you know that was going to happen
you have a feeling I did have a feeling
about this any time you can't really
plan for it you know what I mean so it's
weird it's like I've never been picked
off the first week like that's really
weird for me so I'm having fun just
doing the opening numbers and just like
hanging out with everybody and just
taking it easy this season I guess who
are you rooting for I'm actually rooting
for Rashad I think he can I think he's
got the talent I think he's got the
charm and charisma and I think he's
gonna go super far so I'm rooting for
them how did you react to the max and
Heather elimination yeah I think you
know what that was the biggest surprise
because Heather is such an amazing
dancer and you know what
I felt like she didn't reach her
potential yet I was really sad to see
her go um I think the whole thing was
max being out of the competition
definitely hindered her a little bit I
think um so I wish I would have seen her
around a little bit more but I think
that was a big shocker for sure for
everybody you're gonna be on the dance
with the stars to wear this summer do we
know uh the notes that will be on May
personal living Monday so if you want to
find out if I'm coming on to our not
just tune in
[Music]
you